dhs is rescinding the deportation of an
illegal immigrant who killed 19 year old
adrian sophia exum while he was driving
drunk joining me now ken paxton texas
attorney general rhonda exum adrian's
mother and trinette gamboa adrian's
cousin thanks to all three of you for
being here ronda i absolutely as a
parent cannot imagine your pain when you
heard your daughter's killer was not
going to be deported what was your
reaction
first of all my reaction was
why
i wasn't told in the beginning
you know
that he wasn't going to be deported but
i was told that he was
so i i really want to know why
do you have any sense as to why is there
anything any reason you can come up with
as to why because i can't
that's a good question a very good
question
i wish somebody can tell me
because
i mean to me by him not being deported
it's like
you telling me my my daughter's life
didn't mean anything
i can't imagine what that feels like as
a parent just know that your daughter's
life did mean something i want to make
that abundantly clear trinette how much
of a punch in the gut is this decision
by dhs
it's very unfortunate i was shocked
actually i'm thinking that he was going
to be punished you know
but
like again like they didn't care they
don't care
and i feel like that sense is something
we hear all too often from the victims
and their families why does the
administration not seem to care about me
about my family member about my
situation a.g paxton alejandro mayarkas
says removal quote will be focused on
those who are a threat to public safety
the guy killed ronda's daughter how much
more of a threat does my orcas need to
see
apparently it doesn't really matter i
think i feel sad for this family because
the reality is i believe that biden has
betrayed our country's betraying
families that are losing people right
and left whether it's through fentanyl
overdoses or
crimes or issues just like this
it's it's hard to understand and it is
hard to answer the question of why and i
think the answer to why is that they
have greater goals that are more
important than saving members of
families trinette talk to me a little
bit about what the community that you
live in is experiencing right now have
they been supportive of you and your
fight
oh definitely definitely um
as soon as it happened we had uh just
the outpour of love
and it's it's been amazing
actually
what do they want to see happen to the
guy that killed your cousin
the same thing like
what's going on because it's not only
that he he hit her he took off iran
and that's that's the unfortunate part
too
rhonda what is your message to the biden
administration when it comes to border
policies
well
my message is
look out for the american people first
because
truth be told this was literally my
first
time voting and i voted for you
and
i feel disappointed right now
i don't understand
what did you think joe biden was going
to do for you and what hasn't he done
for you
well i thought he was gonna
you know talk for
the american people basically and not
for himself
and in the year that he's been in office
what have you experienced besides
obviously
a tragedy involving
your daughter and the lack of
sending this guy who did it to your
daughter away
absolutely nothing
i'm sorry
i hope i hope this didn't you know
don't sound wrong but
i i don't feel anything
i don't feel that he has done anything
but disappoint
and again i always ask the why any sense
as to why he hasn't done anything in
this year in office and why he's created
situations where your daughter's killer
gets a stay in our country even though
he shouldn't be here
can can anybody answer me that i would
like to know why i really would
it doesn't make a lick of sense like so
many things that this administration is
doing
it's not what they promised us and it
doesn't make a lick of sense and it's
victims like you trinette and of course
like you rhonda that have to deal with
the consequences we want to thank all
three of you trinette rhonda and ken
paxton for being here ken you do have
a challenge against my orcas on these
changed rules that allow an individual
like the killer of ronda's daughter to
stay in our country please keep us
posted as to how that works and rhonda
and trinette our thoughts and prayers
are with you that's not going to bring
her back but certainly we are with you